mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
quiz los wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
sie schrieb ich bin überzeugt sie schrie
ich mir gesagt dass jeder tag ist das
thema wo sinn macht es sich das thema
weiter dahinter stellen das lichte denen
sich das thema wohnen sich gekostet aber
das buch zieht für tradition kulturplatz
heute über recycling in der architektur
und was es für eine nachhaltige
bauwirtschaft braucht außerdem
[Musik]
die drei fragezeichen seit 50 jahren
bewegen die drei detektive jung und alt
was ist das geheimnis ihres erfolgs aber
ist kann ich zufrieden sein
wir treffen justus bob und titel und
saudi arabien ist an land in dem die
frauen bisher kaum rechte hatten ein
neuer film zeigt wie sich das langsam
ändert
[Musik]
an
ja wir haben auf der baustelle
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz wir
machen heute station in rümlang und hier
wird dieser tage eine ehemalige
kartonfabrik abgerissen und in ihre
einzelteile zerlegt nur was davon wird
wiederverwertet und basiert entsorgt
kann eine baustelle ein ort der
nachhaltigkeit seien die meisten
baustellen in der schweiz sind es nicht
über 70 millionen tonnen abfall jedes
jahr sind die folge davon
das schreit nach zeitgemäßen lösungen
dazu unser schwerpunkt heute
[Musik]
vier fünftel der gesamten abfallmenge in
der schweiz stammen von baustellen das
ist eine riesige verschwendung von
ressourcen würde sich der mensch ein
beispiel an der natur nehmen wäre der
fall klar es ist ein werden und vergehen
aus dem abfahrt von gestern entstünden
so die häuser von morgen und nach dieser
methode werde in mehreren ländern
bereits gebaut dazu heute unter
hintergrund beitrag
die natur macht es vor
ein ewiger kreislauf keimen wachsen und
verdienen
die ressourcen bleiben bestehen
nichts wird verschwendet
anders wenn der mensch gott über 70
millionen tonnen von abbruchmaterial und
bauschutt fallen jedes jahr in der
schweiz an material für den müll
doch aus abfall lässt sich neues
baumaterial machen die wände und die
isolation in dieser wohnung sind aus pet
flaschen
tetra pak und jeanshosen
kartoffelschalen und das ist nur ein
ausschnitt
die wohnung ist eine testanlage der empa
in dübendorf
sie ist bewohnt um die anwendung der
materialien zu prüfen
hier quartieren sich studierende für
jeweils einige monate alt wie lebt es
sich in diesem wohnexpertin end
es fühlt sich gut an
in einem umfeld zum wohnen das
zukunftsweisend ist
denn hier wird abfall wieder zu
rohstoffen man vermissten dieser wohnung
da nichts die ausstattung ist speziell
hier wird abfall zu gold respektive zu
wertstoffen mining nennt das der experte
in rico macau sie in dieser wohnung ist
praktisch alles rezitiert und rezitierte
material ressorts auf dem polit sind
limitiert es geht nur soundsoviel
abbaubares kupfers abend wie ein
das ist tatsache ist der materialien ist
so oder so langsam offenen zustand zu
viel um hat er sich wieder aussortieren
zulässig wo wir gut funktioniert ist
landwirtschaft zum beispiel die küche
und die tibeter haben wir gesagt von
klaus das glas vom hersteller wieder
zurück gemacht wieder ausgeliefert
wir haben den teppich in einzelne zimmer
tätig der hersteller laut dtb komplett
widerruft sei aber weiter und neue
teppiche zu machen
aus dem grund ist der teppich zum
beispiel der kauf der harmonierte wenn
der hersteller wurde apple zurück und so
sind für die meisten australier bezirks
ist die stimmung komponenten sind dort
bereits show fort offen wo die
materialen wie die ständig spiels werden
und das wird wie das gleiche oder sowie
drei business clubs aber um den
materialkreislauf einhalten zu können
ist eines zentral
die bauweise der ausspruch muss ich mir
dass ich das gebäude so der einkauf
materialien das heißt wir haben zum
beispiel darin haben wir keine nicht
wieder lösbarer für windige es ist alles
entwickelt oder gesteckt oder trankovits
überspitzt formulieren sagte das ganze
gebäude zwei liegt mit einem
akkuschrauber voneinander knothe diese
clique aus bronze zierte einst eine bank
und wäre bei einem abbruch im müll
gelandet wie viele andere qualitätsvolle
bauelemente auch die schweizer online
plattform salsa bietet bauteile aus
abbruchhäusern an
gegründet hat sie der architekt olivier
de piero
wir haben in der schweiz zwischen 3000
und 4000 abbruch bewegung pro jahr also
das ist mehr als zehn häuser werden
abgebrochen pro arbeitstag in der
schweiz und man sieht auch was
abgebrochen wird manchmal sieht man den
ausstellungen von bauten die wurde denn
vor zehn jahren komplett renoviert
erneuert und und doch wird das als
abbruch objekt deklariert also man kann
fragt man sich ist das wirklich normal
also ist das eine art und weise dazu
machen nicht das potenzial ist groß auf
salsa gefundene bauteile kamen bei der
brauerei dr gab's im kino zum einsatz
für den architekten bastian turell ein
glücksfall ich habe auf salsa fenster
gesucht und dass sie gefunden
foto das sind fotos vom ursprünglichen
haus in rinnen
da fand ich diese fenster mit holzrahmen
ich konnte 25 davon erwerben für fast
nichts denn sonst hätte man die fenster
weggeschmissen
ich konnte sie für die zwischenwand
verwenden eine zwischenwand die den
aufenthaltsraum vom produktionsbereich
abtreten
[Musik]
nicht immer ist es einfach passende
bauteile zu finden
salsa bietet hier eine effiziente lösung
die idee von salsa ist dass man vor dem
abbruch auf dem foto sieht was es zu
holen gemacht und sich mit dem besitzer
absprechen kann die brasserie doktor
gab's legt wert auf kreislaufwirtschaft
auch die möbel haben ein zweites leben
bekommen das hier ist eine alte tür ist
im gebäude wo die brauerei sich früher
befand die tischbeine kommen aus der
brockenstube wiederverwendung wird in
der schweiz ist wenig praktiziert die
lagerung ist ein problem
auch fehlt es an der akzeptanz in der
bauwirtschaft obwohl es weltweit bereits
zahllose erstaunliche beispiele von
upcycling gibt
[Musik]
warum ist das bauen in der
kreislaufwirtschaft noch nicht gang und
gäbe die baustoffe sind auf dem markt
und die kosten halten sich im rahmen
woran liegt es also es hat mit einem
thema für mich entscheidet store wie
stelle bemüht sind sind sich sind sie
verunsichert sie wissen nicht wie es
gibt natürlich viele jahre spak das sind
rechtliche themen als interpret person
der planerische themen und wie so oft
bis neues verursacht unsicherheit
unsicherheit hemd wie gesagt eigentlich
traut gross sich der große hindrichs
chrome wo jetzt eine andere länder sind
da weiter diese ziegelsteine sind aus
abfall und made in holland
[Musik]
hergestellt in dieser alten ziegelei
südlich von amsterdam in handarbeit
sowie man schon vor urzeiten
ziegelsteine fabrizierte
[Musik]
heute sind sie die basis eines start ups
seit sieben jahren gibt es die firma
stone cycling mitbegründet von
wolfmother so schöne verhalten
das sieht gar nicht mehr nach abfall aus
die ziegel bestehen zum größten teil aus
geschredderten bauschutt und industrie
abfall
[Musik]
da ist auch noch was lustiges dass eine
eigene geschichte erzählt was sich in
der hand halten war inhalte
toilettenschüsseln waschbecken oder
keramikplatten stones eitting erlebt
seit einem jahr einen aufschwung
die farbenprächtigen ziele sind zwar
teuer verkaufen sich aber immer besser
diese farbe hier nenne mir salz und
pfeffer und dieses alarm
es ist immer eine kombination von design
und nachhaltigkeit
die leute möchten ja etwas schönes
kaufen es ist eine win win situation
wenn etwas schön und nachhaltig ist und
schließlich will ja niemand ein
hässliches haus selbst wenn es
nachhaltig ist so findet man die
farbigen steine mittlerweile in vielen
um und neubauten in ganz europa
die niederlande ist ein pionier in
sachen kreislaufwirtschaft das land will
bis 2050 sämtliche abfälle
wiederverwertet
bis 2030 sollen es immerhin 50 prozent
sein
ein ambitionierter plan
es gibt nur eine lösung und den übergang
zur kreislaufwirtschaft zu beschleunigen
hat das sind politische maßnahmen und
zwar nicht nur in form von
steuererleichterungen
das ist ein erster schritt aber besser
ist man verteilt bußen wenn die leute
keine nachhaltigen materialien verwenden
sie schlief ich bin überzeugt sie schrie
ich mir gesagt dass jeder tag ist das
thema wo sinn macht es sich das thema
weiter dahinter stellen das lichte denen
sich das thema wohnen ansicht gekostet
aber das buch zieht für tradition aber
auch die bauwirtschaft hat sich über die
letzten 100 150 zudem etabliert was
ethisch mir redet von global von der
größten größte wirtschaftskrieg das
können sie nicht über nacht um stelle
nicht über nacht aber möglichst schnell
die zeit wird knapp
[Musik]
zurück in rümlang in der schweizer
baustellen realität vom abbruch eines
hauses wird in der schweiz nur ein
bruchteil wiederverwertet gibbs wände
werden abgebrochen und landen in der
deponie und auch die isolation und die
dachziegel werden meistens entsorgt
doch bei diesem abriss sieht es viel
besser aus in sachen recycling
große bauelemente wie die stahlträger
und vor allem der beton kehren zurück in
den bau kreislauf
natürlich fahren wir haben wie viel
verkehr baustellen jetzt darauf stand
wird wiederverwertet
also doch relativ gut da stehen wir mit
80 bis 90 prozent würde man spare bitte
mal viel stahl und das ist leider viel
weniger gut aus und so hofft der
mineralische stoffe haben auch nur über
50 prozent
und wenn man das gucken oder zunehmend
eingesetzt nur schlachten der aushub
wird eigentlich heute was sie in alte
kiesgrube verfüllt dass ich eigentlich
keine seite was braucht es damit die
zahlen besser als buch der generell zum
dank aber wenn der recycling kreislauf
kultur aufbauen und das gut alle und
alle metall und da war es dass das nicht
passiert das problem ist dass viele
akteure am bau beteiligt sind sehr
konservativ und nimmt neue technologie
nicht unbedingt da zum teil hart
baustoffe seiten an der schlachte ruhe
sie haben vorher gesagt hochhuths bauer
aus rezyklierten material wieso passiert
dann
saalfrank vertrauen natürlich ist die
frage vor kurz verdauen aber hat sich
quasi vorbehalt wenn man ja eigentlich
ausgeschaltet
bis bald und deswegen ist sicher so dass
nicht alle gut finden sich gleich gut
obwohl das mittlerweile wirklich an
viele orte bewiesen ist das gleiche
qualität an
was bringt es dann dass es besser wird
funktionieren regulation s jetzt schon
wir haben zum beispiel produkte genau
denen steht dass man eigentlich wenn
immer möglich sagt und baustoff tue dies
dass er dort handelt das zeigt dass
sessions relativ neu und dort hat die ft
haben wir das problem dass umsätze
wieder eigentlich müsste die öffentliche
hand als favorit davor nach vorne
schauen und dann würde die private welt
machen und das sind ein schlüssel stelle
erwähnen muss man überzeugt also in der
stararchitekt also danke sehr schmal und
müsste bauherr wirklich dass ich fordere
die große institutionelle bauherr und am
schluss denn auch die private bauherr
danken wir machen einen großen schritt
und zwar von der baustelle zu den drei
fragezeichen obwohl so groß ist dieser
schritt gar nicht denn die zentrale der
drei detektive befindet sich auf einem
schrottplatz
seit über 50 jahren hält die
begeisterung für die fälle der drei
detektive an
zuerst als buch dann als kassette cd
heute als hörbuch was macht diesen
wahnsinnigen erfolg aus ein fall für uns
[Musik]
angst und schrecken abend für abend
baltes mitternacht geisterspiel
[Musik]
es gibt bei uns
nicht nur kinderbecken
[Musik]
auch die schlafstatt erwachsener wie sie
gar nichts werden von mysteriösen
kriminalfällen heimgesucht die zum glück
immer gut ausgeben
nicht nur in büchern und über 2 höher
spielen auch bei live auftritten lösen
sie einen fall nach dem anderen ein hör
spektakel das tausende in seinen bann
zieht nur wenn sie live auftreten kann
man sie sehen die rolling stones des
hörspiels
die drei fragezeichen das sind justus
jonas alias oliver rohrbeck bob andrews
alias andreas fröhlich und peter alias
jens wawrczeck frühjahr seien sie so
aussehen also dann so und heute zu drei
herren im besten alter die trotzdem nach
wie vor drei teenager spielen also dass
man uns das noch abnimmt ist eine schöne
tatsache wobei wir uns auch nicht
versuchen zu verstellen also wir
versuchen uns jetzt nicht jünger zu
geben oder jünger zu klingen das könnte
man ja auch und müssen wir dann nicht
noch schularbeiten machen aber das hört
sich albern an
sie sind halt älter geworden wie ein
teil des publikums auch früher promotet
von alfred hitchcock da klangen ihre
stimmen so heute klingen die
jugendlichen kriminalist meinem
hörspielstudio so ein laden zurecht
gelegt hast wie wir vorgehen solle
zunächst einmal wenn wir den wagen im
gehörigen abstand taten und uns
vorsichtig zu fuß an den unterschlupf
heranschleichen und dann sondieren wir
die lage
[Musik]
das ist interessant dass es inzwischen
so ein family produkt geworden ist also
es sind ja nicht nur die zehn- bis
20-jährigen die es hören sondern auch
die 50 jährigen also unsere alten fans
die es dann wieder an ihre kinder
weitergeben
ein guter tipp von peugeot wir
recherchieren vor ort anfragen das
publikum
haben sie gesund 18-jährige portfolio
schild und holt m40 er die große welt
ich finde das faszinierend ja so im
jugendalter oder und jetzt wieder von
wien
das passt auch für jene generationen
glaube ich in der woche zum trotz ist
das ganz schön bitter für die alte zu
beginn aber ich kann nicht zufrieden
sein und nicht wie seit wochen kein
fallen arbeit haben aber seit 40 jahren
haben sie erfolg
dessen geheimnis kann detektiv bob
andrews das rätsel lösen
die drei fragezeichen sind ja in sich
sehr spießig muss man sagen also es ist
ja wirklich eine sehr geordnete welt und
sie ist auch eigentlich sehr einfach
drei jungs der eine ist schlau der anruf
sportlich der dritte ist der mediator
der dann ein bisschen recherchiert das
ist ja eigentlich nichts neues aber sie
vermitteln gerade in der heutigen welt
glaube ich wo alles unglaublich schnell
läuft und auch sehr aggressiv ist und ja
auch sprachlich sehr unangenehm werden
kann
eine ein gegenentwurf und dieser
gegenentwurf ist glaube ich genau das
was viele leute auch heutzutage wollen
sehnsucht und nuss dreck fortsetzung
folgt heute abend in ihrem kinderzimmer
[Musik]
zum schluss noch ein blick ins aktuelle
kinoprogramm ab morgen läuft bei uns die
perfekte kandidatin der neue film der
saudischen regisseurin haifa al mansur
sie erzählt die geschichte einer jungen
starken frau die sich in einem land
zwischen tradition und moderne ihren weg
bahnt und so viel vorweg gehen diesem
film geht es unter anderem auch um eine
baustelle
seit zwei jahren dürfen frauen in saudi
arabien auto fahren und mit dieser
einstellung beginnt denn auch dieser
film varian eine entschlossene junge
ärztin will erreichen dass die
zufahrtstraße zu ihrer klinik endlich
asphaltiert wird und kandidiert darum
für den gemeinderat will mitreden trotz
widrigkeiten die entgegenschlagen in
einer in ihren fernzügen immer noch sehr
frauenfeindlichen gesellschaft
die perfekte kandidatin ist der zweite
saudische film der regisseurin haifa al
mansur
sie ist selber in saudi arabien in einer
liberalen mittelstands familie
aufgewachsen aber lebt heute in den usa
mit ihrem ersten film white star der
geschichte eines mädchens das sich
nichts sehnlicher wünscht als ein
fahrrad hat sie vor acht jahren eine
sensation gelandet sie hat den ersten
komplett in saudi arabien gedrehten film
realisiert und das als frau in einem
land in dem kino verboten war
ich habe filme gemacht als es in saudi
arabien noch keinen film gab
ich dachte nie an den erfolg ich wollte
einfach eine stimme haben das machte
mich glücklich die regisseurin will mit
ihren geschichten die saudische
gesellschaft zur öffnung inspirieren
immer sagte immer mitbedacht film kann
definitiv eine gesellschaft verändern
aber nicht auf direktem weg sondern film
und kunst kreieren eine atmosphäre in
der wandel möglich wird und gewandelt
hat sich in den letzten acht jahren
einiges zum beispiel die auflockerung
der strikten trennung von mann und frau
in der öffentlichkeit
es hat sich viel verändert speziell was
film angeht als ich wart stadträte
musste ich als frau die regieanweisungen
mit einem walkie-talkie durchgeben aus
einem lieferwagen und diesmal war ich
auf der straße draußen und habe die
leute direkt angeschrieben
das war sehr stärkend für mich als
weibliche künstlerin
man fühlt sich oft vergehen und machtlos
und muss ausweichen wenn eine religiöse
person auftaucht
auch wenn diese keine offizielle
funktion hat in ihrem neuen film ist es
genau dieses spannungsfeld zwischen
repression und neuen freiheiten
kandidieren ja aber verschleiert
[Musik]
frauen dürfen im heutigen saudi arabien
in die politik ja doch wie fundiert und
verlässlich oder aber kosmetisch saudi
arabiens kurs der öffnung tatsächlich
ist darüber scheiden sich die geister
wir hatten drei dekaden lang keine kunst
kleine kultur und die frauen waren aus
der öffentlichkeit verbannt und jetzt
fließt kultur wieder in das tägliche
leben hinein und das ist sehr wichtig
weil es eine entspannte und tolerante
stimmung schafft und hoffentlich
menschen die warmherzig sind und bereit
sich zu öffnen und dazuzulernen 350 kino
theater sollen gebaut werden
film festivals gegründet das königreich
will den globalen film markt erobern
an ehrgeiz mangelt es nicht und es soll
schnell passieren aber kontrolliert wenn
ich an drehbuchschreiber passe ich auf
dass ich niemanden beleidigen und ich
weiß was nicht durchgehen würde und was
sie finden könnten
für viele ist das frustrierend und das
verstehe ich aber mir ist es wichtiger
mich mit diesen schranken zu arrangieren
so dass der film von der saudischen
gesellschaft gesehen werden kann geht es
in einem land ohne meinungs- und
pressefreiheit filme zu drehen
mansour gilt heute als aushängeschild
der saudischen filmindustrie
da liegt der vorwurf der regime
propaganda nahe sie konnte mit szenen
wie dieser
ihre filmhelden lässt sich nicht von den
männern unterkriegen
heute unser motto
dallas gewann branche harry potter film
ist darin sehr stark es ist ein
unterschied ob man den leuten etwas
predigt oder ihnen eine geschichte
erzählen bei geschichten öffnen sich die
menschen und hören zu und identifizieren
sich hoffentlich damit aber wenn man
hingeht und sagt was richtig ist und was
falsch
dann gibt man den menschen das gefühl
von überheblichkeit von jemandem der
weiß was richtig und was falsch ist
wer weiß das schon beifahrer man so eine
regisseurin in zeiten des politischen
wandels wechsel sonntag übrigens ist die
regisseurin hiv mansour zu gast den wert
sternstunde religion ja das war unsere
sendung von der baustelle hier wir
gesehen im besten fall wird aus abfall
neuer rohstoff und nächste woche bleiben
wir beim thema ökologischer fußabdruck
und schauen ihnen die stadt baden die
ein gewagtes experiment unternimmt kein
plastik mehr ist die devise
da bin ich gespannt wie jetzt geht's
weiter mit dem gast jede bank eine
andere baustelle
[Musik]
unter
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
tourismus
[Musik]